hello everybody and welcome to part
three of our natural language toolkit
with Python for natural image processing
tutorial video if you're familiar with
any of the machine learning video series
that I have you'll find that like I say
most of your work when it comes to any
sort of data analysis is usually
organized an organization of data
cleaning up a data and all that and like
analysis is like right at the very end
it's like the cherry on top that you get
after like 99% of your work is just
about like organizing and structuring
and pre-processing your data so so most
of what n LT K does for you actually is
LT K does not perform the analysis
generally for you it's good you can use
some stuff in a let's see k to test
things stuff like that but for the most
part it's a toolkit so most of what
we're going to cover at least in these
first few videos is just the toolkit
aspect of it and then I'll show you guys
how we can actually use it for analysis
but moving on the next topic that we're
going to be talking about is called
stemming so the idea of stemming is kind
of a it's a form of data pre-processing
and it's a form of not really
normalization but it's the best word I
can think of to compare it to and the
idea of it is you take words and you
take the root stem of the word so for
example if you've got a writing the stem
of writing would be rid basically so you
get rid of the ing and you have a stem
of our ID our ID is applicable to rid
bra or sorry ride riding ridden that
kind of stuff okay so uh what we're
going to do now is well actually first
why might you want a stem okay so why
are we even doing this and the reason
why is a lot of times you're going to
have different variations of words based
on their stems or at least sort of fixes
at the end and but really the actual
meaning of that word is unchanged so for
example let's say we have two sentences
we have I was taking a ride in the
are and they've another one I was riding
in the car okay these mean the exact
same thing but the word ride here is
ride and the word ride ish here is
riding but the sentences mean the exact
same thing and the use of the word here
is identical so if you can imagine all
the words in the English language plus
they're all they're fixations at the end
of them you could imagine that you'd
have a huge database here and a lot of
times you would have two words that
basically mean the exact same thing
taking up space in this database or
table or whatever you're using to get
values on words or meaning even from
words that have the exact same
definition it would be very redundant
very inefficient so we use stemming to
kind of help this problem
so with naturalness processing has had a
stemming algorithm around for a really
long time and it's called the porter
stemmer this one's actually been around
since like 1979 so if you think natural
image processing is like a new thing
adds your problem so anyway um so to use
it with n ltk we're going to go from NLT
k dot stem import porter order stemmer
strimmer stammer and just to just like
everything else there's there are
multiple stammers you can train some
stammers yourself porter stemmer is
actually pretty darn good so we'll just
use it use it for now anyway next we're
gonna say from NLT K dot tokenize import
um we don't really need the cent
tokenizer so we'll just do the word
tokenize tokenize cool now we're going
to say PS vehicle's porter stemmer and
now let's make an example list of words
so example words that's an equal list
and we'll have some stuff in here let's
do five for now okay so let's think of
some example words you've got a Python
you might be a Python yourself it might
be the act of being a Python something
like that then you've got a Python ER
this is someone who pythons
they've got Python in this is someone
who is actively doing the Python then
you have a Python this is generally what
happens when you solve a problem with
Python that problem was Python and then
you've got Python Lee this is just how
you kind of handle yourself he handles
himself Python okay so those are example
words and now let us stem those words
and see what we get so we're going to do
for W in example words and we're going
to do print PS stem W cool now let's go
ahead and run really quick so here are
the stems so as you can see the first
one two through four are all the same
right they all stem down to Python as
the root stem except for the last one
who is python leap okay and so this one
has its own little stem probably because
of the meaning changes slightly but you
could argue the same thing with all of
these other ones but anyway we'll close
that for now and um so whenever you're
stemming like what would a sentence look
like that was stemmed okay so let's see
let me comment this off and let's make a
sentence with our words just to really
drive the point home so new text equals
it is very important to be Python Lee
wow you are Python in with Python all
Python errs have pythons poorly at least
once okay now we're going to say what
happened there we are we're going to say
words equals word underscore tokenize
new text and then again we'll just use
this exact same thing up here for W in
example words only now it is words wads
save and run that it is very import to
be Python Lee while you are Python with
Python all Python have Python poorly at
least well not quite sure why once
stemmed let's see is there any other
iterate once I can't think of more like
I don't sure why it stems down to o NC
anyway Oh fine it's just not meaningful
so as you can see we can stem all this
and important important important the
meaning does not need to necessarily
change that kind of stuff so anyways
that's just a quick example of stemming
with NLT k and kind of why you might
want to stem with n LC k it really
depends on what you do and kind of like
what your goal is because a lot of times
as you'll see as we move forward you
won't actually have to stem and you'll
feed words through n LT K and they'll
actually you'll use word net instead and
word net will actually find you the
synonym using sin set and yeah so really
stemming is something you should know
you should know how to do it but moving
forward you
you may or may not actually ever utilize
stemming because you just don't need to
now that you've got wordnet and sin set
and nowadays even imaging it what anyway
so that's it for this tutorial if you
have any questions or comments on
stemming please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions until next time